y sí
el fútbol despierta pasiones muy
intensas así que es muy difícil mantener
la distancia de seguridad de al menos un
metro en medio de esta pandemia de
coronavirus en el mundo así que las
imágenes que hemos visto en lisboa en
donde se están juzgando cuando se desee
jugó la liga de campeones pues son estas
por ejemplo en este bar que ustedes ven
a mis espaldas donde la gente hace fila
para entrar sin necesidad de mantener
ese metro de distancia pero sí con
mascarilla la única manera de poder
entrar a este recinto en donde además se
toma la temperatura de cada persona que
entra allí pero quizás las imágenes más
impactantes del día de hoy fueron las de
los centenares de hinchas que llegaron a
las puertas del hotel del parís saint
drama para ver a sus jugadores allí bajo
el sol en una temperatura de al menos 30
grados hubo cientos de personas que
estuvieron esperando por al menos 34
horas estuvieron cantando gritando y
aplaudiendo hasta bailando y dando
vítores a sus jugadores cuando los
vieron todos estos los unos a los otros
ahí no había ni siquiera un centímetro
de distancia social entre los unos y los
otros había una que otra mascarilla pero
no era digamos la regla general esto a
pesar de que estaba
y que la policía así nos pidió a
nosotros los miembros de la prensa que
siempre tuviéramos la mascarilla puesta
así que como les decía es difícil
mantenerlas la distanciación social en
mente cuando se trata de celebrar los
títulos de un campeón de europa en todo
caso esta final de la liga de campeones
este jugó sin público